all right let's move on to the next set
of questions which are all about
learning vocab Andrea and Maya could
they want to know what is the best way
to learn new words is it advisable to
learn them in phrases okay so I like
thinking of a language I like thinking
that language is not just the sum of
some words but it's a it's like a
network of words so if you think about
it a person who speaks fluently is a
person who's able to as I said because I
like saying that assemble the pieces
together now when we speak we don't
think about when we use a word we don't
think about the next word when we speak
fluently the next word comes naturally
okay so if you think about it
it's not just about the single words you
have to change your perspective it's not
about the single words that you learn
it's about sentences or context so you
have multiple layers the words are just
the consequence so if you start by
focusing too much of learning words I
think that you're missing the general
picture you have to it's just taking a
look at a picture you see you have to
see the general you take a look at the
frame and you have to take a look at how
the general picture looks instead of
looking at the nuts and bolts
immediately it's you know considering
the language like multiple there are
multiple layers there is a context there
are sentences and then there are words
you know the makeup this is the
sentences so my suggestion is the best
way to learn them well when when people
ask me about the best way I think there
are multiple techniques but I would say
there are some they're important
principles like for example instead of
creating lists there are people who love
lists so if you like that do that but by
all means but I would say that one of
the of the best ways would be to find
texts that you like for example so
remember instead of deliberately trying
to memorize all the words do the
opposite and learn acquired the ability
and the capacity of creating your own
material that you're interested in let's
suppose that you're interested in say
World War two recently for example it
comes to mind right now
I really like history in general
and I recently saw a documentary about
the plague in I don't know if you've
ever heard of that the plague that
devastated Europe and the 14th century
and it got really interested in that and
what I did is I just looked it up on
Wikipedia and I download it you know I I
you you have the option that you can
create a PDF so I created a PDF in
English as a reference you know cuz you
always have to have a reference a crotch
language to help yourself and then I
downloaded it also in Russian and in in
Chinese for example so since I was so
interested in knowing what happened you
know all the details not just the
history there were a lot of things I
learned a ton of words about a lot of
things just by being interested in that
because since I wanted to discover what
happened I really wanted to discover I
started you know reading it and marking
old words etc etc so first of all and a
creator or your own language material
possibly bilingual texts that you know
by comparing how a message is conveyed
in two different languages you not only
understand the single words but you also
understand the meaning the overall
meaning which is pretty important so
this is one very important thing and
then in general you know once you've
done that you can also find a way to a
mark the words now I don't know if
you've ever heard of space-time
repetition mm-hmm
so once you mark the words you can use
you know I always say that this is a
weapon yeah a learning weapon you have a
pencil or a pen you know so highlighter
you can you can simply mark words so you
don't know keep reading keep reading a
text you just keep reading it and then
at the end of it you can use if you have
a bilingual text you don't even use it
because you will infer the meaning of
words just by looking at the version
mean English but if you don't have a
version in English you can always use an
online dictionary so dictionaries are
beautiful but paper dictionaries are a
history right now because with five
minutes if you if you think about it if
you actually do it WordPress comes to
mind which is the most famous but there
are tons of other online dictionaries
you can simply type the word find a
meaning you can even find an example of
that word and you can write it on a
piece of paper so in five to ten minutes
you can actually mark not a lot so you
keep reading the text you mark a little
rewards at the end of it you just write
on the piece of paper
oh the meaning of all the words but now
once you've done that on day X a
beautiful thing that can you know help
you memorize the taxes to watch it to
read the text again a few days later but
you don't look at the meaning because
you wrote it somewhere else on the page
and you just simply read it again and
you will see that if you choose the
right time window you will remember
these words much better then there are
other steps that you can take for
example decide to learn to use those
words to record yourself and use those
words now I cannot tell them to do this
thing but I applied certain techniques
so that this dis passage of marking
words you have to explain it in detail I
expect it in for example in the master
class rush I'm going to explain it again
in the future but it's also about what
you do after which is a way to use those
words and make them important to your
brain because you're telling your brain
that piece of information is it's
important it's all about telling your
own brain that the things that your that
you and it are learning is important
you